the city is falling apart  our boy to show the people of Los Santos  their city doesn't belong to the  criminals had the corrupt these people  they dramatic examples to shake up out  of apathy and I brought into it with my  brand-new dog lethal grapple god I am  the man  Oh a helicopter let's put our we shot at  I won't kill you but I don't have to  save you hey you shouldn't be playing  with God's  you forgot to weigh in at the last  station hey slow down that boy  excuse me this is at the Autobahn  oh look did you miss your exit let me  help you home hey that's Mike let's take  it for a left this balem it's do I  better take this daughter down  oh no you don't  where you going  you didn't pay next stop downtown this  is my kata party I feel like this city  is finally learning  you